Never tell a story without a point and
never make a point without telling a
story. This was a quote I heard from
Valerie Garcia who is an incredible
keynote speaker and it's one of my
favorite quotes that I've heard when it
comes to public speaking and it
reiterates the idea that storytelling is
such an essential part of any speech.
And in this YouTube video, I am going to
give you five of my favorite quotes that
I have received from keynote speakers
that encapsulates what it takes to give
a great presentation. You're going to
want to watch all the way to the end
because these five quotes could
dramatically impact how well your next
speech goes. Public speaking is an art
form. This was a quote from an interview
I had with Swiss Goswami who is a
keynote speaker who joined me on an
episode of keys from keynotes. And what
this suggested is that even though
speeches can have formalities and
structures and every speech has a intro
and a middle and a conclusion or an
ending,
it there's still the ability for you to
be creative within that speech and to
add creative interesting elements. And
so when you start to think about the
opportunity to give a presentation as an
actual art form, that really opens up
the endless possibilities of what you
can do as a speaker. The next quote I
love comes from a speaker named Shan
Kongo who talks about the fact that
there are certain things that might be
beyond your control as a speaker. And
one of those is the room dynamics. You
see, it may be very challenging if you
have a small audience that's in a
massive room like this to make them
laugh even though you present the exact
same material that you presented on a
different day in a smaller, more packed
room that went over really well. And
Sean talks about the fact that the
energy in a room with high ceilings that
spread out, it sort of dissipates and
it's hard to build that laughter amongst
the audience. This is why comedy clubs
often have the low ceilings and
everyone's packed in because it traps
that energy and it bounces off of
everything and it creates this momentum
of laughter amongst the crowd. So you
should know as a speaker that not every
room is going to receive your message
the exact same even if you do a great
job delivering it. But once you know
that, it takes a little bit of the
pressure off of yourself. I was blown
away when I had a conversation with
Jazelle Ugardi on an episode of Keys
from Keynotes, which is my podcast that
focuses all on keynote speaking. And
what Jazelle told me was that she gets
incredibly nervous before every
presentation. and she is someone who has
paid quite a bit of money to go and
deliver her presentations at conferences
throughout North America. And she's a
professional at what she does. But it
got to the point where she explained
before a lot of these speaking events,
she often spends about an hour frozen
with fear in her hotel room and she
can't get out of bed and she's overcome
with these nerves. And then finally,
just before she's about to take the
stage, she switches into this mental
state that gives her the confidence and
the ability to get on stage and to do
her thing and to crush it and she gets
excited about it. But that only happens
a few moments before she takes the stage
where it's hours of dealing with the
nerves. And so if this is how a
professional speaker like Jazelle
experiences it, I think that that should
take a little bit pressure of pressure
off of you if you do experience those
nerves or anxiety because it's important
to know that even the pros get nervous.
This is part of it. But once we know our
nervous tendencies,
that's where we can be prepared and it
becomes a lot more predictable. One of
my favorite quotes about public speaking
came from Sabiasachi Sen Gupta who is
the 2015 sorry the 2025
Toast Masters International World
Champion. And I had never heard it
described this way before, but Sabi
talked about Toast Masters as sort of
being like a playground. And he said it
is that sandbox environment where you
can experiment and you can try things
out. and you are in front of a safe
space, a safe audience who wants you to
succeed. And I think practice is the
single most important thing to improve
your public speaking skills. And if we
think of Toast Masters as that place to
practice, to put in the reps, but also a
playground to challenge ourselves, to
experiment with different mediums,
there is a ton of value of joining a
local Toastmasters club. And my final
favorite quote when it comes to public
speaking came from Muhammad Katani. And
Muhammad was the 2015 Toastmasters World
Champion. And he has this incredible
story of how he had a stutter as a child
that was so bad and he was so nervous
about it. He would never speak up in
class. But he had a friend who
challenged him to go and read the school
announcements and it was humiliating. He
was made fun of every single day. But he
kept challenging himself and pushing
himself to do it. And in my conversation
with Muhammad, he talked about the
importance of facing our fears,
especially when it comes to public
speaking. And the fact that when you do
it, it's not going to be easy. It's
going to be very challenging. But the
more reps you put in, the more you get
right in front of it, it's going to
eventually over time get easier and
easier and easier. And who better to
give that example than somebody who was
frozen in fear about stuttering, who
went on to become the world's best
public speaker. I hope this video on
some of my favorite quotes from
professional keynote speakers has added
value to you. If you're somebody who's a
professional or an executive and you
want to get more serious about your
public speaking skills, check out my
standtore link below and see how we can
work together in private one-on-one
sessions. Also, check out the video that
is popping up on your screen right now,
which YouTube is recommending. And if
you could subscribe to my channel, that
is the best way to help me create more
of this content. Thanks so much.